hello reject nation Gregg al Bakir John
Humphrey here sorry number I'll scare
hey Mike and you seriously so so we've
covered it now no plans no actions note
singing but robot boys heck yeah
well that just because that resembles
who you are on the inside yeah I know I
am a robot I don't feel anything
sure I bet you're very much you could've
been much closer than true
no one can eval are the greatest people
I know how we're going to watch this
video leave requested how to avoid Game
of Thrones spoilers from a wonderful
channel called the warp zone they're
amazing to help you haven't seen them go
subscribe to them immediately I am three
episodes behind so this is good advice
for me yeah like even when I'm an hour
behind it's still good we do a patron
today shout out for a man named Matt
beer Matt very very rare we gotta get
now Matt bye area we'll do it after the
reaction we'll do it alright time for a
new episode of Game four oh man wonder
what's gonna happen you live who see the
guys or we get the boots I can't wait oh
no oh god I love me the whole episode is
nothing yet but ha everything - all
you're gonna do is just get one wolf day
without getting sport how hard - daddy
hey man wait yes so thank you I can't
talk right now I gotta go oh hey Dan oh
man could you believe it when John Doe
gets he'll be by later
[Music]
quite the turn of events tonight I can't
walk he has good coffee on himself
without any outside in your hands gonna
go get some help in I'll definitely be
right back okay made to my miss me
you say keep my head down look some
woman every single day man uncle slam
dispensing the whole world is talking I
think that actually works now I'm cell
phone battery on a new year old iPhone 8
out damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
hey Dad once talking about the walkers
before you O or God so then I'll check
not some Game of Thrones
theory forms with afternoon and they all
seem to think that when they have a good
job
Wow Wow what the home and this TV show
it's not TV it's HBO
oh boy
[Music]
got deep end man
[Music]
I was waiting for that one hey guys
thanks for watching their code guys
subscribe to the warp zone if you
haven't already they're at my lean and a
half followers but increase that
following that is that was so [ __ ]
history it's because I've never seen a
warp zone video but my expectations when
I read that headline we're just so
dressed you guys know it's so well done
that was so well shot - well yeah
whatever when it ramps up in the second
half that was like a different
production yeah expecting because like
the way they shot that and like the
frame rate and the crazy whip banning
like I thought I was watching a number
of Exile Island resin I loved sketches
that start off like normal and then
slowly escalate and then go batshit by
the end of it and the first half is very
true and accurate is been caught in that
situation where water flying back from
New York to LA and there was just not
like I couldn't watch it before I got to
the office the next day and sure enough
it's like you open the door they're all
sitting at the damn conference table
talking but I go over to my desk head
north on it's not drowning it out it's
so true I feel like everybody nowadays
has a day like that and mine was when
the season premiere of Walking Dead
Season 7 was on earlier than watching
Walking Dead and I was like way behind
and I was at work I was at Horror Nights
and like AMC was on in the break room so
like I had to strategically avoid the
episode and I did such a good job and
then like the next morning comes like
you haven't when I was like haha gosh
yeah I mean I hate how they started off
with like not even asking if you've seen
the episode yeah it'll just start like
all the things that you don't want to
hear dude or like social media posts
like a social so like Instagram he is
the worst with any office I actually
give them a pass because really most of
us do watch Game of Thrones and really I
mean even when I watched it my committee
often someone else might not
I just assume everybody else I won't go
in and blurt out spoiler but still I
assume everyone who has seen it
social media is a different freakin i've
actually surprised it and tackle that in
that video but social media is a major
problem saying that show starts there
are spoilers injures oh yeah oh yeah you
gotta you gotta give up electricity
until you yeah so and that's what I
loved about the sketches that
capitalizes on the paranoia and then the
rage you feel when someone spoils it
isn't like isn't extreme lengths to
avoid a [ __ ] spoiler I was a
hilariously I wasn't expecting that I
thought it might just have been like
some level one step one and they do like
an act out bit oh yeah he expected them
to go like a full-on short film about it
I thought this is going to be like
yelling exploring a number of little
micro sketches in a scenario via this
was a nice surprise you know especially
when it hits peak whimsy like before
they got a bit when he's just like
firing staples it is pretty inspiring I
really can't believe how well they
pulled that off yeah it really does look
good like the camera works great and you
know it's got the bright red blood which
is obviously like cheesy and fake but
that plays into it it was I'm very very
impressed well and it is a workplace
massacre so I feel like cheesy blood and
help yeah to be playful with that yeah
that is why we can laugh and have fun
with something like that for those yes
series yeah exactly and the first video
is done that beer that beer is a person
we've talked to a couple times on our
Google hangout Mattia or that's croc to
shrimat ale my Hefeweizen have a license
all they drink that that stuff on the
Game of Thrones I just wanted a Matt
beer I've got her to know you and
there's one thing that I picked up on
that you haven't talked to me about I
could tell you're a pervert I like know
for that I like you for that let's just
be honest me man we need like a perverts
union it's like very obvious don't know
why I ever come here and I'm still
shocked by this way reason and they
always got to her Minds or people to
show you a place for them to gather yeah
Gus Andy refurbished ever bumper sticker
to put on your car well Matt beer has it
on his car proud of the perverts you
know that's not a burger that's a great
guy he's really easily very rooted might
move out to California actually and if
you're here buddy we're going to totally
hang out my friend because we love you
for you we won't spoil Game of Thrones
for you subscribe to the real rejects
click bells of notifications don't worry
they don't do anything and John is that
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram P
Nemiroff is Twitter and Instagram go
follow her constant bikini photos no
pictures of her cats
now she's half negative photos all the
time it's exactly all I care I'll have
to be half naked clothes and then like
monologues underneath them about you
know like self-help about yeah yeah
teryn I am the pair get used to it
what else does she do some of YouTube
chances a part of Collider and she's
also uh she has her own channel - mm-hmm
yeah I read them off is her channel yeah
well like I should keep it simple